-Performing the hit title track
to his newest EP, "Buy Dirt,"
here is Jordan Davis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Few days before
he turned 80 ♪
♪ He was sitting out back
in a rocker ♪
♪ He said "What you been up
to lately?" ♪
♪ I told him chasing a dollar ♪
♪ And in between
sips of coffee ♪
♪ He poured this wisdom out ♪
♪ Said if you want my two cents
on making a dollar count ♪
♪ Buy dirt ♪
♪ Find the one
you can't live without ♪
♪ Get a ring,
let your knee hit the ground ♪
♪ Do what you love
but call it work ♪
♪ And throw a little money
in the plate at church ♪
♪ Send your prayers up
and your roots down deep ♪
♪ Add a few limbs
to your family tree ♪
♪ And watch their pencils marks,
and the grass in the yard ♪
♪ All grow up ♪
♪ 'Cause the truth about it is ♪
♪ It all goes by real quick ♪
♪ You can't buy happiness ♪
♪ But you can buy dirt ♪
♪♪
♪ Before you get caught
on that ladder ♪
♪ Let me tell you
what it's all about ♪
♪ Find you a few things
that matter ♪
♪ That you can put
a fence around ♪
♪ And then he laid it out ♪
♪ Buy dirt ♪
♪ Find the one
you can't live without ♪
♪ Get a ring,
let your knee hit the ground ♪
♪ Do what you love
but call it work ♪
♪ And throw a little money
in the plate at church ♪
♪ Send your prayers up
and your roots down deep ♪
♪ Add a few limbs
to your family tree ♪
♪ And watch their pencils marks,
and the grass in the yard ♪
♪ All grow up ♪
♪ 'Cause the truth about it is ♪
♪ It all goes by real quick ♪
♪ You can't buy happiness ♪
♪ But you can buy dirt ♪
♪♪
♪ And thank the good Lord
for it ♪
♪ 'Cause He ain't makin'
any more of it ♪
♪ Buy dirt ♪
♪ Find the one
you can't live without ♪
♪ Get a ring,
let your knee hit the ground ♪
♪ Do what you love
but call it work ♪
♪ And throw a little money
in the plate at church ♪
♪ Send your prayers up
and your roots down deep ♪
♪ Add a few limbs
to your family tree ♪
♪ And watch their pencils marks,
and the grass in the yard ♪
♪ All grow up ♪
♪ 'Cause the truth about it is ♪
♪ It all goes by real quick ♪
♪ You can't buy happiness ♪
♪ But you can buy dirt ♪
♪ And you can buy dirt ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]